we begin the day with another chapter in
the ukraine russia standoff
representatives from both countries met
in person today together with their
german and french counterparts in paris
the four-way normandy format has been
used repeatedly since russia's
annexation of ukraine's crimean
peninsula in 2014.
also tonight washington has delivered
its written response to russia's
security demands we don't know the exact
details of this letter but we do know
that the u.s and its allies have not
budged on some demands like keeping the
door open to nato membership for ukraine
the letter is the latest step in the
ongoing diplomacy over fears of a
russian invasion here's what the u.s
secretary of state had to say
today
ambassador sullivan delivered our
written response in moscow
all told it sets out a serious
diplomatic path forward should russia
choose it
the document we've delivered includes
concerns of the united states and our
allies and partners about russia's
actions that undermine security
a principled and pragmatic evaluation of
the concerns that russia has raised
and our own proposals for areas where we
may be able to find common ground
i expect to speak to foreign minister
lavrov in the coming days after moscow
has had a chance to read the paper and
is ready to discuss next steps we make
clear that there are core principles
that we are committed to uphold and
defend
including ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity and the right of
states to choose their own security
arrangements and alliances
russia's foreign minister also spoke
today and criticized western countries
for taking an aggressive stance against
moscow here's what sergey lavrov had to
say
you
the west is using all these hysterical
statements to make their position clear
therefore i will not speculate about our
western partners
they are weak and apparently
do not really know how to get out of the
ampas into which they have got
themselves
as we mentioned this all comes as
high-ranking officials from ukraine and
russia met face-to-face along with their
counterparts in france and germany to
hold negotiations in the normandy format
and dw correspondent christine munoz has
been following those talks for us hi
christine how much does what we just
heard from both anthony blinken and
sergey lavrov there reflect what you
have seen coming out of the negotiations
sumi those talks in paris we're told
lasted some eight hours they were
described as the russian official as
very difficult in nature but it appears
the remarks coming outside
of that meeting are more conciliatory
there was a lot of talk about agreeing
on certain issues the bulk of those
discussions were on the situation in the
donbass region that is in eastern
ukraine where i have to remind you sumi
that 15 000 people have been killed
there since 2014 when a separatist
conflict broke out now the russians for
their part say they are not party to
that conflict but coming out of this
meeting the diplomat or the
representatives from moscow did say that
russia was willing to exert its
influence on the separatists in the
donbass region we're also told that
they're going to be meeting again in
about two weeks time
and we believe that meeting could be
taking place in berlin
and will potentially also be attended by
the foreign ministers of the four
respective countries
christine we know that the west has also
been discussing what uh their possible
response would be in the case of a
russian invasion of ukraine and that
would include a number of sanctions so
we heard u.s president joe biden saying
he would consider sanctioning vladimir
putin personally which russia says would
be politically destructive how does
europe see this
well we haven't heard
a european leader say the very same
thing but i do want to point out the
issue around what the european leaders
are planning here they are basically
making plans for the event that there is
an interruption of gas supply to the
european union from russia
europe depends on on russia for about a
third of its gas supply and it is feared
that that supply could be interrupted
either by caused by the conflict or as a
retaliation from moscow in fact gas
supply is seen as mr putin's strongest
economic
measure that he could
retaliate with so
you are seeing a lot of plans being made
with the help of washington as well in
terms of what could happen in the event
that gas supply from moscow to the
european union is interrupted because it
would make for a very cold winter here
in europe if that were to happen
dw correspondent christine mundo in
brussels there thank you
nato has also sent a letter to the
russian government responding to the
kremlin's demands to the military
alliance nato secretary general jens
stoltenberg repeated his assertion that
a russian invasion of ukraine would come
with severe costs he called on moscow to
de-escalate the situation and admitted
that the west and russia are still far
apart but he also said diplomacy and not
war would provide a solution to the
crisis
so we are now
reaching out to russia once again
to try to
pursue a path of dialogue and to find a
political solution we are also prepared
for the worst
and therefore imparted with our
efforts on the dialogue track and we are
also
increasing the readiness of our forces
we can get some more perspective on this
story now speaking to richard sakwa he's
a professor of russian and european
politics at the university of kent and
the author of the books russia against
the rest the post-cold war crisis of the
world and frontline ukraine crisis in
the borderlands mr sakhwag very good to
have you with us on the day i want to
ask you first of all about what we've
seen through the course of today namely
these written responses
from washington and from nato to
moscow's security demands i know that
this is really just the latest step in
the diplomatic process but how do you
think these will be received in moscow
well it depends what they say we know
that washington asked moscow not to make
public their contents until there's been
a chance to have diplomacy about them so
i think it's an important step forwards
because it's engaging with russian
concerns the degree to which they're
going to have flexibility we don't know
but it's certainly a an important step
towards possibly the de-escalation of
the most immediate threat
okay so an important step forward have
you seen beyond that any signs of all of
this diplomatic activity we've seen
really over the last few weeks actually
moving the needle in the standoff
well it hasn't uh in fact uh um the
powers western powers have been arming
ukraine that don't forget there's a
hundred thousand ukrainian if not more
uh hundred thousand ukrainian troops on
uh its own um eastern border and one of
the reasons why russia mobilized it
don't forget this is the second time
they've been doing it uh the first time
was april 2021 and a lot of the forces
remained was that russia feared that
ukraine would do what happened to
nagorno-karabakh the azerbaijani uh
armenian war uh the last year
so it's the year before so it's a um
there's a military aspect to it and
there's a diplomatic aspect and i think
we should be really careful to separate
the two
i want to ask you a bit more about the
military aspect of it because it does
seem to all parties involved very
unlikely that ukraine would join nato
anytime soon so why would vladimir putin
be making this step now i'm asking
really about the timing of this
yeah there's two things about that
one of them is that
the ukrainian issue is part of a larger
one and that is the european security
order that was established after the
cold war and this is something that
putin's been concerned about and before
him yeltsin and gorbachev that is nato
enlargement and the fact that they argue
not only was the promise not to enlarge
nato um betrayed but also that uh their
view that in security is indivisible and
that's one of the founding principles of
the paris charter for new europe so
there's that larger issue but why now
that putin is coming to the end of his
term in 2024 he may come again but
certainly the idea was after 30 years
they really need to resolve the big
issues and obviously ukraine is the
front line of that
if we look at the current situation
right now on the ground you have said
that you are skeptical that an actual
invasion is on the cards at the same
time we see this russian buildup of
troops a hundred thousand more than a
hundred thousand troops heavy missile
systems arsenal armor as well so
what would that positioning be for if
not for an invasion
well an invasion um the window for the
invasion is closing because uh within
about a month or a bit longer you have
what's called the yes put itself which
is the thaw and so any heavier armor
which you mentioned wouldn't i mean it
could when modern equipment go but we're
talking about long-range missiles and
aircraft and so on if it comes to
military action but it's also the uh the
beijing uh winter olympics starting in
early february and uh there's quite
clear that uh beijing has made it clear
to moscow it doesn't want any military
action before then
and secondly the russian force posture
isn't ready for any actual invasion it
really is saber rattling and this is
where the analogy with the cuban missile
crisis does work 60 years ago kustov
maybe foolishly actually nevertheless he
got a certain element out of it which is
a removal of the jupiter missiles out of
turkey which is what started it all in
the first place
and i want to just follow up on that
because you have called this a slow
burning cuban missile crisis
and a situation where both sides will
have to find a way to allow the other to
save face
what could that possibly look like at
this point
yeah
i mean the first thing is diplomacy and
i think the first step in uh the the
cuban missile crisis so it's
de-escalation was not to keep saying
that some things are non-negotiable but
the first issue is to
stop the immediate crisis and then come
to some second deal how it could look
like
one of the first things is that clearly
nato membership isn't as you mentioned
on the cards for ukraine but perhaps
some sort of long-term promise two or
three decades to say uh ukraine won't be
joining nato and second no other armed
forces military elements and alliance to
put
what forces what they now calling
ukraine a huge uh aircraft carrier park
next to russia and also uh the question
of ukrainian neutrality and some people
argue this is completely outrageous but
on the other hand it was the official
position of ukraine until december 2014
so it's not that outrageous and
obviously austria finland
ireland have thrived within those
conditions so
the immediate thing is to you know to
try to keep the forces and stop it
becoming military and the second thing
and then is this says it were the
outlines of a
larger security deal for the whole
continent
we'll have to leave it there richard
sakwa professor of russian and european
politics at the university of kent uh
thank you so much for joining us on the
day
my pleasure
nato and the united states have each
delivered their response to moscow
security demands amid tensions over
russian aggression towards its neighbor
ukraine at recent joint meetings moscow
demanded a guarantee that ukraine would
never join nato and that the alliance
would seize military activity in former
soviet republics now u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken said washington
has set out a serious diplomatic path to
resolve the conflict he added that the
u.s made no concessions to the main
demand on nato membership for kiev and
speaking a short time ago nato secretary
general jen stoltenberg said it was time
for both sides to improve dialogue and
diplomacy by re-establishing their
respective offices in brussels and in
moscow and here's more of what
stoltenberg had to say
we call on russia once again to
immediately de-escalate the situation
nato firmly believes that tensions and
disagreements must be resolved through
dialogue and diplomacy
not to force
or the threat of force
so today nato has conveyed our written
proposals to russia
we've done so on we had we've done so in
parallel with the united states
for more on the story we can speak to
gustav gretel he's a security policy
expert from the european council on
foreign relations hi gustaf good to have
you with us we've heard there that
moscow has now received the written
responses to security demands both from
washington and from nato do you think
this will move the needle at all in
diplomatic progress
unfortunately i don't think it will
change much because moscow's demands was
written in a way that actually a
rejection of them or a polite rejection
as as they might have gotten it now
uh
was
un unevitable and and this was
consciously chosen in moscow to write it
in a way that uh
make the western nato reject it the
thing is what happens thereafter will
moscow use this as a pretext for war
or will some of the as i said polite
rejections that said that uh over some
concerns and issues there will be put
path forwards uh to negotiate on them
will those be taken as honorable uh
off-ramps to
de-escalate the situation that depends
whether russia takes the sanctions
threat seriously that depends whether
russia thinks that a war uh
will cause it more trouble than it will
gain from given the increased support of
european and u.s
uh nations to
to ukraine particularly in the military
field that remains to be seen we don't
know the decision on this yet okay so
you say that this back and forth of
these letters actually are not going to
make much a difference in terms of
diplomacy and dialogue
you mentioned sanctions there and
whether moscow will take that threat
seriously and and you have said that
only very severe sanctions will have any
effect on vladimir putin's
decision-making so what do you define as
severe sanctions
like putin thinks that russia can only
survive the 21st century if it's an
empire not only by land force but also
by population and by by governing over
industrialized west sort of
industrialized
cities and and and centers and that
includes ukraine so he thinks that this
is a very important strategic objective
for russia and you will only
scare him if you put up sanctions that
would foil the plan for russia being as
strong and mighty and survivable in the
21st century as he wants it to be and
that means sectorial sanctions in the
energy sector one way or the other
and a a large decoupling of the european
and north american consumer market from
russia because that
undermines russia's financial resources
and its technological and societal bonds
to that market
uh uh and to to to european technology
still as such uh that russia also
perceives necessary for being sort of
the kind of modernist modernized great
power that it wants to be other kind of
diplomatic shaming
uh and even freezing put his personal
assets as important that is as a message
i don't think it will make him rethink
what he's doing but hold on a minute
gustav is it really that clear that
vladimir putin is intent on invading
ukraine because there do seem to be real
questions being asked about that
here in berlin and certainly in brussels
as well
uh yes a lot of european countries think
that the situation is not that serious
the problem i mean i'm a military expert
i look from it from willie point of view
and if i look at the formations at the
logistics at the preparation it's pretty
serious um
we also see other worlds that russia
usually uses when it leverages exercises
or or deployments to threaten or to
bargain uh the the
the threats against ukraine have been
pretty consistent the demands have been
out there
and
the willingness to use military force
have been underlined by putin himself by
lavrov himself uh uh
at with the same wording consistently
over the last three months so i think we
should take that seriously
okay very interesting we'll have to
leave it there gustav gressel from the
european council on foreign relations
thanks for sharing your perspective with
us today
thank you very much